i'm moving
i'm losing and that's winning if you're
the first to lose
you won hi what's up i'm molly waynes
and this is 90 second trivia
with the academy
okay before you go i'm just gonna say
i'm probably gonna lose but i'm just not
gonna forfeit first question yes
what movie does robert de niro's famous
line you talking to me come from taxi's
driver where was aretha franklin born
detroit incorrect
greenville maryland
chicago rydell high school is the
setting for which influential 70s
musical movie
it would be grease correct how many
total grammys did aretha franklin win
crazy for asking me
16.
incorrect
julian andrews won the best actress
oscar for which 1964 musical
because she asked me some really hard
answers yeah some questions who what
what who was the julie andrews or what
uh
the one she was on top of the mountain
sound of music
who said we're singing in the rain
incorrect
what song did aretha sing in the 1980
film the blues brothers
r-e-s-b-e-c-t
well why are you doing this
oh you better think that was my thing i
think yeah okay jody foster played fbi
agent clarice starling in what 1991 film
that would be silas
what was the first feature animated
movie released in history
the first feature animated film was
probably 10 seconds mickey mouse
something incorrect snow white
that's what it meant what is your
favorite aretha franklin song
my my song is respect
correct and time's up
i didn't get eight
um
felt like two days
when you're wrong
time moves real slow
trust me
you